hey guys you know when you're young
you think you know everything you're
pretty smart
or at least that's what i thought when i
was younger
but then as i grew older i realized i
was pretty stupid when i was 18.
i thought i was smart especially when i
talked to older people
i mean what did they know but then i
realized something
there's a huge difference between being
smart
and being wise so in this video i want
to share with you
seven things that i wish i knew
when i was 18. let's get to it
[Music]
[Music]
just very quick if it's the first time
that you're here my channel i'm daniel
and welcome to my channel if you haven't
subscribed yet then please consider it
and also click that notification bell so
you won't miss any of the future
videos here we make videos about fitness
grooming style and
life itself
[Music]
i'm not like other people you might not
believe this now
most of you that's been watching my
videos for a while but i also try to fit
in
with the people around me now this is
not always a bad thing because you
always need to
read and adapt the context the situation
that you are in
but you don't always have to go along
with something
if you don't believe in it if you don't
agree with it
i am unique you are unique and other
people
are unique we are not the same and it's
okay to be different
in a good way not a bad way so
i stayed silent about many things
and i should have spoken up with
confidence against things
that were not right never let group
pressure
control you stand up for what is right
one of my favorite quotes says our lives
begin to
end the day we become silent about the
things
that matter by martin luther king jr
people come and go but family
sticks you know i never knew when i was
young that i would lose two of my
brothers
and recently my father and then when it
happened
regret came in if i only took more time
to spend with them
and to fully appreciate them and all the
memories of things i could have done
differently
and today i miss them a lot at 18
i did not appreciate my family enough
not as i should have and i hope that you
can learn from my lesson
life is short focus on the things that
really
matter your family yeah your family is
one of them
there's a quote that says having
somewhere to go is a home
having someone to love is a family
having both is a blessing
some people will not like you it's not a
great feeling
when you know that someone does not like
you
it was harder for me because i grew up
in a family that had a lot of love
so we were always nice to each other and
then
it bothered me when someone did not like
me until i realized
that's just life haters are going to
hate
and i can't do anything about it they
hate for different reasons maybe they
had a bad day
or a bad life and they just take it out
on you
maybe they're jealous or maybe the only
way they feel good about themselves is
when they step on other people
whatever the reason accept the reality
of it and when it happens just
brush it off because you can't let other
people steal
your joy and your peace listen
it's impossible to make everyone happy
because we're all different and we come
from different backgrounds so it's
impossible
so my advice to you is just always be
you
and focus on doing the right thing
[Music]
never put a limit on what you can do
yeah it sounds
cheesy but it's true the moment you put
a limit on yourself on what you can do
and what you can accomplish
that's the moment you will not reach
your full potential
you don't know what you are capable of
doing
if you never give your best i mean be
realistic
with your dreams your goals but don't
put a limit on it
for example if you want to be a great
singer but don't have a good voice
it's probably not gonna happen be
realistic but
chase after the things that you are good
at and have a passion for
that is what gives you purpose for this
life
that is what you were created for
[Music]
laziness is your worst enemy
i thought i was smart always searching
the quickest fastest way to do something
just to get it done and i never gave my
best
i never did something really properly
when it came to academics in school only
later in life i realized that i was just
shooting myself in my foot because it is
not the end result
that makes you better it is the journey
to the end result
that improves you let me give an example
of something i did
when i was still in school i loved rugby
and when i went to practice
exercise i always cut my workout in half
whenever the coach was not looking
for example you have to run 100 meters
and back as fast as you can and i would
run
and then look if the coach was not
looking i would turn around and then i
would think
i'm smarter than everybody else i was
just shooting myself in my foot because
then
when pri when um the real match will
come
i would not be as fit as the other guys
and it's the same when it comes to life
itself you will reap
what you saw and if you sow laziness
you will reap poverty and failure
[Music]
you can't control time and death
you know as you grow older you will come
across the reality
of death you will lose friends and
family
loved ones you might be able to control
a lot of things in your life
but you cannot control time and death
you cannot fight the reality of it the
truth of it
these days a lot of people say my truth
is my truth your truth is your truth
well no truth never changes only your
perception of the truth
changes it doesn't matter what you say
what you believe
the reality is still the reality if you
say well i'm not going to lose anyone or
i'm not going to die
well of course you are you are not
immortal
and just like all the generations before
you you too
will die someday maybe when you're 70
maybe this year 150 000 people
die every single day and then
where will you go when you die what will
your family say about you when you die
your friends what will they say about
you don't waste
your life the time that you've been
given but make the most of it
you brought nothing into the world and
you're not gonna take anything out
so start to think really hard on what
matters
most i wish i did it when i was 18.
[Music]
your actions cause reactions from other
people
that you know that most of the time you
can change a situation
instead of complaining about it most
people don't even realize that their
actions cause other people to react
in a certain way so you actually teach
people
how they should treat you and you don't
even know it
being arrogant puffed up and pushy will
just lead other people
to dislike you and avoid you but on the
other hand
being overly kind humble considerate
without being bold and confident in who
you are
might let other people walk all over you
so you need a balance
never be arrogant and puffed up but
always be confident
in who you are be confident in what you
stand for
and then do it with humbleness
kindness gentleness treat other people
the way you want them to treat you
but then always remember to adapt
depending on who you are talking to
there are wolves out there so be as wise
as serpents
but as innocent as doves now
if you haven't subscribed yet please
remember to do so and also if you want
more self-improvement tips
then watch one of these videos here and
i'll see you there cheers guys